we know about Donald Trump's endless
golfing right we've talked about Donald
Trump golfing a lot at his own golf
clubs and part of it is that Trump by
golfing at his own golf clubs so
frequently is funneling taxpayer money
into his own businesses that's one issue
but with Trump there's always some
double standard or hypocrisy and you
might remember that Donald Trump would
slam Obama relentlessly when when
President Obama was president for
golfing a little bit and Donald Trump is
golfing more than any president in the
history of the United States and the
golfing is becoming such an obsession
such a distraction really that Trump's
golfing is now interfering with his
duties as president of the United States
and you are paying for Donald Trump's
golf you're paying for Trump's travel to
the golf courses your money is being fun
yours and mine by the way I'm not exempt
from this I'm just as impacted by this
as you are your money is being funneled
into Donald Trump's resorts because of
the entire apparatus that travels with
him that is booking rooms and renting
golf carts every time Trump goes goes
golfing but it is now taking Trump's
attention away from being president you
can make the argument that that's a good
thing
right if you believe that the less Trump
does the better off we are that's an
argument you can make we want Trump not
doing president stuff but he's still
raping and pillaging taxpayer money to
play golf and we should all be against
that particularly you would imagine a
fiscal conservative so-called fiscal
conservatives 102 days donald trump has
now spent on the golf course during his
first ten months as president donald
trump tweeted and the White House
claimed during Thanksgiving that Donald
Trump would be working on job creation
and other very important issues during
the holiday turns out that he basically
played golf the entire Thanksgiving
vacation and he also broke another
promise which was that while he was
president Trump told us his company
isn't going to be working with foreign
entities part of Donald Trump's vacation
was spent surrounding the work going on
with Trump
world golf club Dubai which is now under
development in as the name suggests
Dubai another broken promise from the
campaign and Donald Trump also sending
unhinged tweets during the Thanksgiving
holiday you'll recall that for
comparison President Obama last
Thanksgiving went to work at a
retirement home for military veterans
last year he did something similar in
2015 he worked at a soup kitchen in 2014
George W Bush was also known for some
volunteering on national holidays
meanwhile Donald Trump is golfing and
sending angry tweets while development
of his foreign golf course continues and
forget about how progressives interpret
this Shiki nuri of publishing a busy
schedule and then ending up just golfing
how can anyone on the right defend this
i am i every time we do a story like
this i ask for someone on the right who
believes that this is ok or a good thing
get in touch with me explain to me how
you defend this explain to me how this
fits into the idea of personal
responsibility
the idea of hard work the idea of
working for the little guy none of it is
happening absolutely none of it is
happening under Trump because he's the
epitome of the man who should never be a
public servant because he thinks that
the public is there to serve him not the
other way around
and again the only silver lining I can
think of here is that we really don't
want Trump dismantling society in
government and if he's playing golf
presumably it's a break from destroying
our country and the fact that taxpayers
are paying for it is the problem the
fact that it's a it's another one of
these horrible double standards from
Trump is part of the problem the fact
that Trump lied endlessly about he would
never really leave the White House and
wouldn't have time to play golf because
he'd have so much to do that's the
problem and we also have to realize that
the destruction and the dismantling of
the US will continue even with Trump
when Trump is golfing because whether
Trump is golfing or not a GTI is going
to continue trying to repeal net
neutrality
one that Trump appointed wet-weather
Trump is cheating on the golf course and
and and trimming the number of strokes
required to get those non-existent hole
and ones remind that reminds me of a Kim
Jong moon or a Kim jong-il rather in his
golf lies whatever Trump is doing
whether he's in the Oval Office or on
the golf course Scott Pruett at the EPA
is taking that agency apart and that is
why you need to vote in every single
election and we'll be talking about Roy
Moore's special election on December 12
and starting to gear up for the midterms
very very soon that is the solution
hoping Trump golf so he doesn't do
president stuff it's not gonna work
because the people he's appointed are
still going to get things done we'll
take a break back with more right after
this